all right let's hear from a few more
people we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to Skyler in New York
Skyler welcome to the program uh what is
on your mind today
and how's my audio it's beautiful
great so um I wanted to ask you about
the ongoing uh battle between Disney and
Ron DeSantis yes um on one hand I do
tend to agree that Disney as a
corporation is way too powerful and the
idea that they can basically self-govern
can be a bit of a red flag and you know
generally there are a lot of other
aspects about Disney that are damaging
to the free market to labor to the
environment
I'm really enjoying how Disney continues
to humiliate the Santos and the amount
of elves that they keep handing him now
I don't really think the SanDisk is
taking some sort of principled stance in
this whole bottle it's this whole battle
it's obviously just cultural and over
the don't say gay stuff and Disney
allegedly being woke but I'm curious
David where do you fall in this whole
battle I think that I share your
concerns with the idea that a
corporation can essentially work as a
self-governing entity I don't like that
I think it's not a power that should be
delegated to corporations and and with
that I agree 100
I do believe that DeSantis and this
anti-woke movement has overplayed its
hand as it applies to Disney and more
generally uh there's polling that now
I've discussed a number of times that
shows that the majority of the American
public it's not a huge majority but it
is a majority actually falls on the woke
rather than the anti-woke side on a lot
of these different issues including
trans LGBT Etc so so I believe that it
is a bad strategic decision for DeSantis
in Florida to Target uh Disney not only
over issues where the the majority of
the country is actually with Disney but
also because Disney is so beloved you
know I hate theme parks but a lot of
people love them and people like the
Disney characters and the movies and all
that it seems like a bad uh decision to
pick a fight with Disney tactically as
well
yeah and you know my biggest like I
don't know if it's a concern or just
observation is is obviously the
continued escalation over you know what
being anti-woke actually means
um you know I I don't know where it ends
like at this point we're having a whole
war on like Western society and culture
um whether it's education whether it's
Medical Science whether it's you know
culture and religion it just I I don't
know like where the end point is so let
me address that if you ask people on the
right they would say the anti-wokness
ends when we defeat wokeness my view is
that's never going to happen because the
country has become more and more woke I
mean when you if we think about wokeness
as sort of like enlightened left-wing
ideas the country keeps moving more and
more in that direction so I think
anti-wokness ends as those ideas become
less and less common
and when Republicans realize they're not
going to win with anti-wokness then
they'll move on to the next thing
yeah it's interesting how a lot of the
you know sort of corporate wokeness that
gets you know derided by the right by
big corporations tends to typically only
exist in the social sense and that a lot
of times this corporate wokeness doesn't
really trickle down to like improve
Progressive progressivism around labor
or equitability 100 and that's because
for a lot of these corporations they're
just taking the view they determine to
be more socially palatable and it's
because that's what's most profitable
exactly all right well thank you very
much for taking my call David all right
thank you great to hear from you there's
Skyler in New York with a very uh
interesting and important issues being
being brought up